[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام واحييكم وهذه اخبار
الظهيره مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
بمسيرات مفخخه وصاروخ باليستي ايران
كرديه شمال العراق واشنطن
محاكم وعرفيه واعتقالات التعسفيه لقمع
الاحتجاجات والحرس الثوري يلوح مجددا
بالقبضه الحديديه
موسكو كيف تتبادل الاتهامات عن قصف محطه
زابوريجيا وتحذيرات دوليه من اللاعبين
بالنار
بعد استقالات جماعيه عصفت بمنصه تويتر
اليوم موجه اقالات جديده تنتظر مئه
العاملين
مشاهدينا سنبدا اولا من ضربات ايران
الجديده والتي استهدفت مواقع تقول انها
تابعه لاحزاب المعارضه الكرديه الايرانيه
في اقليم كردستان شمال العراق اجهزه
مكافحه الارهاب في كردستان العراق اتهمت
الحرس الثوري بالوقوف وراى عمليات القصف
فيما اكد الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني وايضا تنظيم قوم لا طبعا هو
القوم الكردي الايراني ان هذه الضربات
استهدفت منشات تابعه للحزبين في هذه
المنطقه بشمال العراق بدورها افادت وكاله
الانباء العراقيه الرسميه بتعرض مقر ثلاثه
احزاب ايرانيه معارضه داخل اقليم كردستان
لقذف بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره
الايراني يدعونا تابعه
باي باي
اخلاقي
نا
واخلاق
[موسيقى]
المزيد ينضم الينا من الحدود العراقيه
الايرانيه مراسل العربيه احمد الحمداني
اهلا بك احمد بدايه اي جديد حول هذه
الاستهدافات والخسائر ان كان البشريه او
الماديه
ثلاث مواقع للمعارضه الايرانيه في اقليم
كردستان العراق الاول في مناطقه المحافظه
السليمانيه المتاخمه للحدود العراقيه
الايرانيه وموقعين في اربيل الاول ضمن
حدود بلده همم اربيل العاصمه وهي وكان في
الضاحيه الشماليه من اربيل وهي منطقه
بحركه ومقر كومه ايران المعارضه الايرانيه
التي استهدفت
بالطائرات المسيره المفخخه
وطبعا استهدفت مجمع سكني في تلك المنطقه
لعائلات المشرده من ايرانيه
لعائلات ايرانيه مشرده همم منذ ثلاث عقود
في هذه المنطقه وايضا استهدفت
المقر اللي همم كويسنجه وهو للحزب
الديمقراطي الايراني الم لطيران في مناطق
كويسين جاق وهي منطقه تتبع اداريا الى الى
اربيل العاصمه
وتتبع وامنيا الى محافظه السليمانيه ضمن
محافظه السليمانيه لكنها في في المناطق
الشرقيه من
الاربيل همم البارتي او الحزب الديمقراطي
منسون قال لي ان سقط قتيل من همم من
بيشمركه كردستان ايران في هذا القصف الذي
كان عبر اربعه صواريخ ارض ارض همم قصفت
المقر والدمرت وايضا استهدفت المنازل
اللاجئين العراقي اللاجئين الايرانيين في
هذه المنطقه وهذا طبعا هذا همم الاستهداف
يكون الاول من نوعه ان تستهدف من المناطق
والمنازل المدنيه بعد تهديد الحرس الثوري
الايراني بشكل واضح انهم سوف يستهدفون
المواقع المئوده
احمد الخسائر الماديه على الاقل او
البشريه بالاحرى نتحدث عن قتيل واحد هل
يعني انه هذه الضربات فشلت همم في
الاستهدافات وبالمقابل حجمها كيف كان
طبعا بدايه هي لم اا لم ااه
تعطي نتائج كبيره بحجب الصواريخ والمسارات
كون ان المقرات جميعها جميعها خاليه من
المعارضه الايرانيه وان ال ال ال الشخص
الذي قتل او ال- ال- بيشمركه الكردي الذي
قتل في هذا المكان يكون هو من ضمن حراس
المباني الفارغه ما قرات اخليت من قبل
المعارضه الايرانيه حاله ما كان هناك سامي
بتهديدات الحرس الثوري وبالتالي هم قصفوا
اماكن غير ماهوله وخاليه وليس فيها معارضه
ايرانيه من الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه
مراسل العربيه احمد الحمداني شكرا جزيلا
لك
طبعا فيما يتعلق بردود الفعل على هذا
القصف الايراني دانت القياده العسكريه
الامريكيه للشرق الاوسط دانه هذه الضربات
اعتبرت ان هذه الهجمات تعرض المدنيين
للخطر تنتهك وايضا السياده العراقيه طهران
كانت قد شنت اكثر من مره هجمات صاروخيه
جدير بالذاكر ان هذه الهجمات الجديده
استهدفت مخيم جزيل كان كما استمعنا وهو
للاجئين الاكراد الايرانيين بالقرب من
بلده بحركه في اربيل وذلك بحسب ما افادت
وسائل الاعلام كرديه على كلن ايضا للمزيد
حول هذه الضربات معنا من اربيل الكاتب
والباحث السياسي كفاح محمود اهلا بك سيد
كفاح اذا استهدافات لمقار لاحزاب ولكنها
كانتاليه هل هي الرسائل فقط ام ماذا ما
وراء هذا الاستهلاف الان
صباح الخير الايرانيين يدركون جيدا يعني
النظام الحكم في طهران يعلم جيدا بانه
المراكز التي تم قصفها او يتم قصفها منذ
فتره طويله هي اا ثلاث مخيمات رئيسيه في
كوريا وفي شمال اربيل في منطقه بحركه وفي
سليمانيه وهذه المخيمات يرجع تاريخها الى
سبعينيات القرن الماضي همم وهي تضم لاجئين
او هاربين من من من ظلم من النظام الفحل
او في حينها واضيفه اليهم الهاربين ايضا
من جور ما يسمى بالثوره الاسلاميه في
ايران بعد 79 ومعظمهم بالتاكيد من
المدنيين بالتاكيد ايضا هنا كثير منهم من
المعارضين لكن النقطه المهمه الاكثر
الاكثر اثاره الانتباه انه ال- ال- حمل
السلاح ممنوع في كردستان يعني هناك قوانين
صارمه بهذا الاتجاه ويخضع
للمسائله القانونيه فكيف تتهم ايران ان
هذه المراكز او هذه المخيمات ترس الاسلحه
الى المنتفضين عموما انا اعتقد الايرانيين
يحاولون الخروج من حاله الاقتناق السياسي
داخل ايران تصوري استاذ ميسون خلال خمسه
ايام قتلو اكثر من 36
تتضمن النقطه الرئيسيه التي اتحدث عنها
انه استهدافات في الخارج الايراني كيف لها
ان تهدئ في الداخل والمقابل هي تزيد من
الضغوط الخارجيه همم استمعنا الى القياده
العسكريه همم انتقدت مثل هذا الاستهدافه
وايضا يثار الان قضيه هذه همم الضربات ان
كانت التركيه من جهه او الايرانيه من جهه
التي تضرب سياده العراق
سيدتي الكريمه بالتاكيد عمليه التخفيف عن
الضغط في الداخل هو هذا التهييج الاعلامي
بالتاكيد قصف اقليم كردستان سيبعد وسائل
الاعلام المحليه والعالميه والعربيه عن
الاهتمام بما يجري في الشارع الايراني ومن
ثم يتم تهميش ما يحدث في ايران على حساب
عمليات القصف التي تجري هنا عموما انا لا
اعول على على الدوري الامريكي وردود
الافعال التي لم تتجاوز تصريحات يعني
متميعه او همم
قوات المنطقه الوسطى
على الداخل الايراني على الداخل الايراني
على الداخليه الايراني المركز ايضا لا
يتجاوز همم رد فعله عن رد الفعل الامريكي
بالادانه والاستنكار هناك موقف مبهم
للرئيس الامريكي وهذا يرتبط بالمصالح
الامريكيه في المنطقه وتحديدا مع
الايرانيين هم لا يريدون ان يخسروا ايران
بالمطلق ولا يريدون ان تكون ايران اي ااا
شرط الخليج بمعنى هناك اشياء خفيه ربما
وراء الكواليس تهم المصالح الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه والا كيف سمحت امريكا لتركيا
بقصف مراكز لقوات تتحالف معها وتسلحها في
سوريا هل هناك اكثر من علامه استفهام
يعني لم تصل الى مستوى الثوره انا اعتقد
الان الشارع الايراني برمته منتفض رغم
قساوه ما يحدث وعمليات القتل المستمر
للمتظاهرين لكن يوما بعد اخر تسديد يعني
هذه الانتفاضه ربما ترتقي الى مستوى
الثوره الى ما دعمت عربيا واقليميا
وعالميه
كفاح محمود شكرا جزيلا لك
طبعا البعثه الاميه في العراق شددت على
ضروره الهجمات واقفه هذه الهجمات التي
تنتهي كاسياد العراقيه البعثه الامميه
اشارت الى ان مثل هذا العدوان لا يزيد
التوترات على نحو طائش فحسب بل ويتسبب
ايضا في وقوع ماسا اضافه البعثه انه ايا
كانت الحسابات الخارجيه التي تسعى دوله
مجاوره الى تسويتها طبعا هنا الاشاره الى
ايران فان استخدام الادوات الدبلوماسيه
المعمول بها هو السبيل الوحيد للمضي قدما
من هجمات ايران في العراق الى قصف تركيا
على مناطق سيطره قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
في ارياف محافظه حلب والرقه وايضا الحسكه
قصف ادى الى سقوط قتلى وجرح مدنيين
وعسكريين على حد سواء بينما قال المرصد
السوري ان عدد قتل الضربات التركيه على
شمال سوريا ارتفع الى 35 ذكرت وكاله هاوار
الكرديه ذكرت ان القصفه التركي تجدد على
الريف الغربي لمدينه عين العرب طبعا هي
تابعه لمحافظه حلب السوريه مصادر كرديه
افادت ايضا بان قصفا بالمدفعيه الثقيله
وقذائف الهاون استهدف بلده شيوخ فوقاني
محيطه طبعا الناطق الرسمي اعتبر ان لدى
تركيا رغبه في التوسع وفي ضم المزيد من
الجغرافيا السوريه كما اضاف ان قصد لن تقف
مكتوفه الايدي ستدافع عن مناطقها حياه اي
توقل
في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل بتهمه دعم
الاحتجاجات الايرانيه قمع يا طال فنانين
وايضا ايرانيين
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره ونكمل
من التطورات في الداخل الايراني القضاء
الايراني اصدر حكما بالاعدام على شخص سادس
طبعا على خلفيه مشاركته في الاحتجاجات
المستمره منذ حوالي شهرين محكمه ثوريه
دانت المحتاج بيتهم سحب سكين بقصد القتل
بس الرعب خلق حال من انعدام الامن في
المجتمع هذه الاحكام تاتي في الوقت الذي
يواصل فيه المحتجونه احتجاجاتهم الليليه
في عشرات المدن الايرانيه طبعا تضامنا مع
مدينتي مهاباد الكرديه التي اشارت تقارير
الى ارتكاب القوات الامنيه الايرانيه
حملات قمع غير مسبوقه فيها
[موسيقى]
الساعه 11:8
الايراني ضد المحتاجين ومن يدعمه الامن
الايرانيه ممثلتين على خلفيه خلعه هما
الحجاب طبعا دائما للاحتجاجات الاعلام
الرسمي الايراني
بحسب اعلام ايراني رسمي فان القضاء
الايراني
مع سبع شخصيات معروفه سينمائيه وسياسيه
والرياضيه بسبب نشر المحتوى وصفه الق
بالاستفزازي دعما لحركه الاحتجاج هذه
الصور وهذا الفيديو الذي خرجت فيه الممثله
خرجت بدون حجاب ربطت شعرها كمل شاهدنا في
هذه الصوره وهي اشاره دائما ما تستخدمها
النساء قبل الاتجاه الى المشاركه في
التظاهرات كما نشاهد في هذه الصوره
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا هذا بالنسبه للاعتقالات اما
فيما يتعلق بالتحركات الامنيه على الارض
فقط قام الحرس الثوري الايراني بتعزيز قوه
البريه في محافظه اذربيجان الغربيه شمال
غربي البلاد لماذا هناك هناك تقع العديد
من المدن الكرديه خاصه مها باد التي تشهد
كما ذكرنا سابقا مظاهره شعبيه واسعه
القوات البريه التابعه للحرس الثوري في
محافظه اذربيجان الغربيه زعمه ان
التعزيزات تاتي لمواجهه ما وصفته
بالتحركات الانفصاليه في اشاره طبعا الى
الاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه المعارضه وقد
توعد الحرس الثوري المحتاجين بما وصفها
باجراءات حاسمه لردعهم وفي المقابل اعرب
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه عن قلقه من تصاعد
العنف ضد المتظاهرين في ايران خاصه في تلك
المدينه مدينه مهاباد قال ان واشنطن تسعى
الى محاسبه المسؤولين عن العنف وتواصل دعم
الشعب الايراني على كل بمعنى من واشنطن
الخبير في الشان الامريكي والعلاقات
الدوليه ايهاب عباس اهلا بك سيد ايهاب قبل
قليل كنا نستمع الى رؤيه من العراق تتحدث
عن المواقف الامريكيه تقول ادانات فقط لا
تحرك هل في الملف الداخلي الايراني يمكن
ان يتغير ذلك كيفيه دعم الولايات المتحده
للداخل الايراني
ات الامريكيه ضعيفه وليست على المستوى
المطلوب لا هي ولا الاذنات الاوروبيه همم
والولايات المتحده يبدو انها لا تلقي
كثيرا من الاهتمام للشعب الايراني الداخلي
وهنا في الواقع استاذه العزيزه اريد ان
اسمي همم موقف الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
الذي وضع اربعه شروط لعوده الولايات
المتحده للاتفاق النووي كان من بينها ان
تعامل ايران شعبها طبقا لحقوق الانسان
والديمقراطيه المطلوبه على مستوى العالم
وهو ما لا تقوم به الحكومه الايرانيه همم
ولذلك همم اليوم همم الديمقراطيون برئاسه
الرئيس
لديهم مثل هذا نهج وليس مهتمين بالشكل
الكبير فيما يتعلق بسلوك ايران سواء
داخليا او خارجيا مع جيرانها في المنطقه
وفي اقلامها المحيط
ويتعاملون مع ايران فيما يبدو على انها
دوله مارقه امر واقع يعني
ستظل مرقه ويجب ان نتعامل معها بانها
اصبحت امر واقع وليس هناك المزيد مما
نستطيع ان نقول
الراي العام يمكن ان يكون له تاثير في
الولايات المتحده على القرارات السياسيه
في تحركات على الارض من قبل المتظاهرين في
تحركات من قبل لوبيات تدعم حقوق الانسان
وتحديدا للمراه المتاثر الاول بهذا الاطار
هل يمكن ان همم يكون لها دور فاعل او لا
يعني بالاضافه مما ذكرتيها حضرتك هناك
لوبي ايراني ايضا معارض موجود في الولايات
المتحده ويحاول بكل بكل ما اوتي من قوه
للتظاهر وايصال الصوت الايراني المعارض
وانا اشاهدهم دائما في العاصمه واشنطن
يقومون بالتظاهرات خاصه امام البيت الابيض
تاره ومره اخرى امام وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه والتحميل طبعا القوانين
الامريكيه الخاصه بالتظاهر ولكن للاسف
الشديد الاداره الامريكيه تعلم ماذا يحدث
وتلتقي بهم بالمناسبه ولكن لا تحرك ساكنا
وان حركته تحركه بالمستوى الاقل من
المطلوب همم بالاضافه اللي جماعات الضغط
الاخرى كما ذكرت حضرتك العامله في مجال
حقوق الانسان وحمايه الديمقراطيات وهم
ايضا لديهم ضغوط قويه لكن للاسف الشديد
الاداره الامريكيه لا تتعامل بالمستوى
المطلوب الذي من شانه ان على الاقل يعني
يجعل النظام الايراني يفكر ما قبل ان
يعتدي على مواطنه للاسف الشديد او على
جيرانه على الاقل تقدير
في شان الامريكي والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب
عباس شكرا جزيلا لك
وفي سياق اخر قالت الخارجيه الايرانيه
انها سترد على قرار وكاله الطاقه الذريه
باجراءات جديده في منشاتين طنز وفودو وصف
الوزير الخارجيه الايرانيه القرار الاخير
والذي طبعا تبناها مجلس محافظين وكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بخصوص طهران وصفه
بانه سياسي وايضا صدر بضغوط من واشنطن
والدول الغربيه
ومشاهدين ننتقل الان الى الملف الاوكراني
وعلى خلفيه القصف الذي تعرضت له محطه
زبوريجيا الاوكرانيه اعتبرت الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان ما يحدث هو
اللعب بالنارك مواصفات
كارثه كبرى اكدت الوكاله عزمها اجراء
تقييم للاضرار التي لحقت بالمحطه مشيره
الى ان هناك اضرار لحقت بالفعل ببعض
المباني والانظمه وايضا المعدات في الموقع
لكن هذه الاضرار لا تشكل اي خطوره على
السلامه والامن النوويين حتى الان من
جانبه قال الرئيس الاوكراني
ان القوات الروسيه تقصف مواقع اوكرانيه
على الخطوط الاماميه بالمدفعيه وان
المنطقه الشرقيه وحده تعرضت لما يقرب من
400 ضربه يوم امس نستمع اليه
يا كراميشنا
تقع في منطقه دوناتس وعلى الرغم من وقوع
عدد اقل من الهجمات اليوم بسبب سوء
الاحوال الجويه فان حجم القصف الروسي لا
يزال للاسف مرتفعا للغايه في منطقه لوكانس
نتحرك ببطء الى الامام اثناء القتال وحتى
الان وقع ما يقرب من 400 هجوم مدفعي في
الشرق منذ بدايه امس
ننتقل الى ملف طائرات ايران المسير والتي
تشعل مخاوف اسرائيل مجددا اسرائيل قدمت
احتجاج الى روسيا على خلفيه التقارير التي
تحدثت عن تزويد ايران للروس بطائرات بدون
طيار في حربها على اوكرانيا هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه الرسميه قالت ان سفيره
الاسرائيلي في موسكو احتجها لدى الخارجيه
الروسيه بشان حصولي روسيا على روسيارات
ايران كما اوضحت الهيئه ان اسرائيل تشعر
بالقلق بسبب تشكيل محور روسي ايراني مؤخرا
وانها تخشى ارسال ايران صواريخ بالستيه
قصيره المدى لروسيا على غرار الطائرات
المسيره
في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل رؤيه
ضبابيه وعاصفه جديده تنتظر العصفور الازرق
موجه اقاله جديده قد تعصفه بالعاملين في
تويتر تابعونا
بمسيرات مفخخه وصاروخ بالستي ايران تستهدف
احزان كرديه شمال العراق واشنطن تندد
محاكم وعرفيه واعتقالات تعسفيه لقمع
الاحتجاجات والحرس الثوري يلوحوا مجددا
بالقبضه الحديديه
موسكو وكيف تتبادلان الاتهامات عن قصف
محطه زابوريجيا وتحضيرات دوليه من اللعب
بالنار
بعد استقالات جماعيه عصفت بمنصه تويتر
اليوم موجه اقالات جديده تنتظر مئه
العاملين
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره ونكمل
من العصفور الازرق ينتظر العاملين في
تويتر موجه التسريحات جديده اليوم وذلك
بعد استقلال جماعيه شهدتها الشركه يوم
الخميس الماضي مراقبون يقولون ان عمليات
الاستقاله التي ينوي تويتر الجديد لهم
ماسك عليها ستر على الموظفين المشاركين في
المبيعات وايضا الشركات ماسك كان اصدر
انذار النهائيا للموظفين اما بالبقاء مع
زياده ساعات العمل او الاستقاله مع مكافاه
نهايه الخدمه
لثلاثه لاشهر على كل المزيد معنا من سان
فرانسيسكو مراسل العربيه حسين الطود حسين
ما الذي ننتظره في هذا اليوم
تحيه لك ميسون بالفعل وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه اشارت الى نائلهم ماسك قد يقدم
اليوم على اقاله المزيد من الموظفين لكما
تفضلتي في الخبر طبعا هناك حديث عن تضارب
في اداره ايلون ماسك لهذا المنصه المهمه
يقيم موظفين يطالب البعض بالعوده لطالب
البعض التقدم اذا كان يوجد البرمجه هناك
تخبط يطالب موظفين من الشركات اخرى يملكها
مثل تسلم بان يساعد ورسمها الموظفين
التقنيين بان يساعدوا همم في همم الصيانه
موقع تويتر اليوم ماسك كان امام تحدي كبير
في الحقيقه مع بدايه كاس العالم غرد قبل
كاس العالم طلبه بمتابعه تويتر من اجل
تغطيه افضل بعد بدايه كاس العالم غرد ايضا
وضع فيديو لافتتاح هذا الحفل الكبير ايضا
اليوم كان هناك موقف بالنسبه لسي بي اس
شبكه سي بي اس نيوز التي اعلنت انها عادت
لتغ واعاده للنشاط على شبكه تويتر بعدما
توقفت مؤقتا بسبب حاله عدم اليقين كما
ذكرت التي تشوب المنصه همم نتبقى الكثير
اليوم في الحقيقه مع اا عوده الموظفين الى
المبنى الرئيسي في سان فرانسيسكو وايضا
احتمال عوده او مجيئ بعد الذين استقالوا
لاخذ اغراضهم الشخصيه من هناك لانهم منعوا
جميعا من الدخول الى المبنى اليوم يوم مهم
طبعا سنكون متابعين له منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى هنا في سان فرانسيسكو هل من
معلومات او هل من عمليه القاء الضوء على
مصيرها هؤلاء الذين استقاله طواعيتا همم
ماذا عن هذا السوق الان الى اي حد هو
مهزوز بصوره عامه
بحسب ما نقرا ميسون سوق ااا التكنولوجيا
الان يقال انه يعاني ان نحن نتحدث فقط عن
تويتر بل ايضا على الفيسبوك وعن
شركات الكترونيه وشركات تقنيه اخرى ولكن
في منطقه فرنسيسكو هنا يعني هذه المنطقه
لوس انجلوس سان فرانسيسكو هناك العديد من
الشركات ولكن في ظل التخوف من حاله ركود
اقتصادي يتحدث الكثيرون عنها المصير في
الحقيقه مجهول لا نعرف ان كان سيكون هناك
اخرى له
لا سيما كما قلت في ظل حديث عن ازمه او عن
ركود اقتصادي وعن حاله تضخم كبيره بطبيعه
الحلقه الامر لن يكون سهلا نحن لسنا في
افضل الاوضاع الان نحن نعيش اوضاع صعبه
بالنسبه للتضخم بنسبه لزياده الاسعار
وبالنسبه للانكماش العديد من الشركات الان
لا تدخل الاموال لا تدخل على الاموال في
الاعلانات هذا كله يؤثر على التوظيف هنا
في الولايات المتحده ايضا رغم انه حسب
البيانات الاخيره التوظيف ما زال مرتفعا
ولكن هناك تخوف من انكماش في المستقبل
بحسب طبعا كما قلت الارقام الرسميه وايضا
التحليلات التي نقراها
العربيه حسين الطاوت شكرا جزيلا لك
وستكمل هذه النشره باخبار رياضيه ولقاء مع
ضيف في الصحف الرياضي اشرف محمود من
القاهره اهلا بك استاذ اشرف اسمح لي ان
ابدا بالحفل بصوره عامه قبل الدخول
بالتفاصيل واداء المنتخب القطري همم هل
وصلت الرساله وكان الحفل بحجم التوقعات
وحجم الاموال التي دفعت
بدايه تحياتي لحضرتك ولكل مشاهدي العربيه
في كل مكان
الحفل جاء كما كان متوقع حفل مبهر مبهر من
حيث استخدام الليزر والالوان والاضاءه حفل
مبهر من حيث الفكره التي رصدت الثقافه
العربيه من حيث اللقاء الحضارات او لقاء
ما بين العالم الذي يلقب الاول والعالم
الثالث او العالمي من خلال المشهد الذي
ظهر فيه مواطن قطري مع ممثل امريكي
والحوار الذي دار بينهما ايضا استخدام كل
ما يرمز الى البيئه العربيه سواء سمكه
القرش او سماء سواء المراكب بالنسبه
لمنطقه الخليج كل هذه الاضواء العالم خلال
استخدامها سيد اشرف تتعلق باظهار همم
الامير وهو يلعب كره القدم وايضا همم
اضافه سياسيه بالمصافحه الشهيره بين
اردوغان والسيسي دعنا ندخل الان الى اداء
المنتخب القط لماذا
المنتخب القطري كان مخيبا للامال في هذه
المواجهه رغم انه منذ اكثر من اربعه اشهر
متفرغ للاعداد القوي لهذا المونديال الذي
تستضيفه بلاده وكان ينبغي ان يكون اداؤه
مواكبا لحفل الافتتاح مواكبا لما تم
انفاقه من
ضخم الامكانات ماليه لاظهار هذا الحدث في
ابهى صوره المنتخب بدا مرتبكا بدا خائفا
بدا متراجعا واستغل ذلك المنتخب ودوري
ونجح في خطف ثلاث نقاط سهله على طبق من
ذهب بهدفين نظيفين وكان بالامكان ان يزيد
غلتهم من الاهداف لكنه مدربه همم فاطمه
الى ان المنافس ليست له انياب حقيقيه
فاراح لاعب به وحتى فالنسيا الذي احرز
الهدفين همم اخرجه من المباراه واكمل بعدد
من العناصر اجرى تغيرات والخمسه كامله في
ما مدرب المنتخب القطري يتاخر كثيرا في
التغيرات وربما محمد ممتاري البديل الذي
دخل هو الذي يعني همم اظهر وجهها حقيقيا
هجمه وحيده في الشوط الثاني على تلعارضه
تصويبته لكن اجمالا ربما الخضه ربما الخوف
ربما القلق ربما التوتر
من ماذا من الجمهور من الحضور يعني كان
على مستوى على المستوى العربي عالي جدا
نعم نعم ان تتحدثين عن اكثر من 60 الف
متفرج في الملعب هذا رقم لم يكن موجودا في
الملاعب القطريه من قبل تشجيع مثال العالم
كله يتابع هذا اللقاء كل لاعب يريد ان
يظهر اقصى ما لديه من قدرات يؤكد جدارته
باللعب في المونديال لكن هذا الامر همم
انعكس بالتوتر الذي افقد الفريق همم
تركيزه اولا او انسجامه ثانيا لم يعد
الفريق يقدم لنا لوحه جماعيه هي لمسات
فرديه لعدد من اللاعبين همم بود يرفع
اعتقد هو الافضل في كريم ضيافه الافضل في
هذه التشكيله مع عبد الكريم حسن ما دون
ذلك لم يظهر اي من اللاعبين بمستواه
العادي المعتاد
وتوزيع ايضا حتى المعلق قال انهم همم لا
احد متواجد الان حيث تذهب الكره
بالفعل يعني ربما الزميل العزيز يوسف سيف
هو المعلق القطري المخضرم كان يومي النفس
بان تكون مباراه الافتتاح التي يعلق عليها
بعد انتظار طال حلمه باللعب في المونديال
للعنابي لكنه لم يتوقف عن اظهار الحقيقه
التي يراها في الملعب وانتقد الفريق بشده
وانتقد المدرب على تاخر التغييرات المنتخب
القطري كما ذكرت لحضرتك حرما اللاعبون من
اللاعب في المنافسات المحليه طيله الشهور
الاربع الماضيه افقدهم هذا الامر كثيرا
كان رهانا خاسرا من المدرب الاسباني ان
يمنع اللاعبين من المباريات الرسميه
التنافسيه التي تزيد من الجاهزيه فقط
وكانهم في همم معمل والمعمل لا يفرز الا
اداء باهت بصراحه صحفي الرياضي اشرف محمود
شكرا جزيلا لك
الان الى ناصر واخبار الظهيره الاقتصاديه
ناصر تفضل
الخسائر بعض الشيخ تتعمق في اسواقنا خلال
جلسه هذا اليوم بالرغم من انه الخسائر
ليست قويه او فادحه من حيث النسب السوق
السعودي ينخفض بدون هو الاكثر تراجعا
حقيقه هو والسوق الدوحه باكثر من واحد في
المئه وينخفض مؤشر السوق السعودي الى ما
دون الاحد 10,000 نقطه وذلك لاول مره منذ
السابع والعشرين من سبتمبر حين كنا قد
سجلنا انخفاضات في المؤشر خلال الجلسه
انترديدون لا 11,000 نقطه واغلقت وقتها
السوق دون الاحد 10,000 نقطه ايضا هذه اول
مره نعود الى تلك المستويات الاكثر تداولا
مجموعه تداول همم على انخفاض الى همم ما
دون المئه و 160 ريال طبعا صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه تخرج من 10% اضافيه في
المجموعه تداول عند سعر المئه و91
منذ الاعلان عنها قبل اكثر من اسبوعين
والسهم على انخفاض مستمر تراجعات على
الاهلي باكثر من واحد في المئه الراجحي
متراجع بنصف النقطه المئويه وانها البارحه
اكتتاب باصدار صكوك ب 10 مليارات ريال
سابق منخفضه ايضا بواحد ونصف النقطه
المئويه ومعادن بنفس النسبه في سوق دبي
ايضا تراجعات بقرابه نصف النقطه المئويه
اعمار تضغط على المؤشر سته دراهم لا تزال
فوقها بالرغم من ذلك اتحاد العقاريه كانت
مرتفعه باربعه وخمسه في المئه خففت
مكاسبها في هذه اللحظات دبي الاسلامي ايضا
على تراجع اما في ابو ظبي كنا قد شاهدنا
اي اتش سي وملت بلاي على استقرار هذه
الجلسه وما زال تقريبا على استقرار همم في
جلسه اليوم تراجع على حديد الامارات اركان
بنصف النقطه المئويه واستمعنا طبعا بانه
ادنوك للحفر المستقر سهما همم اشترى ثلاث
منصات حفر بحريه بقيمه 200 مليون درهم في
الكويت مؤشر الكويت الاول متراجع ب 20
نقطه المئويه تراجعات مستمره منذ بدايه
الصباح على زين الكويت بقرابه ثلاثه في
المئه ولكن معظم الاسهم المصرفيه مستقره
بيتك والوطني على بعض الارتفاع الوطني
تراجع على كيبكو بواحد ونصف النقطه
المئويه همم في سوق الدوحه
التراجعات بواحد فاصل اربعه في المئه قبل
بدايه او مع اغلاق جلسه الامس مكاسب السوق
منذ بدايه السنه كانت اقل من اربعه ونصف
النقطه المئويه ولكن تراجعات وهمم واسعه
النطاق على همم الاسهم القطريه خلال جلسه
هذا اليوم هذه كانت اذا وقفتنا مع الاسواق
نعود الان من جديد الى الرياض ومع زميلتي
ميسون
شكرا ناصر
بعد فشل الكثير من المشاريع الهادفه
لانقاذ البحر الميت من الانحسار كشف
الجانبان الاردني والاسرائيلي عن اعلان
نوايا جديد يهدف لتاهيل مياه نهر الاردن
وتعزيزها كرفض رئيسي للبحر الميت وتحضر
الدراسات من زوال هذا البحر بعد 50 عاما
الوقوف هنا قبل سنوات
البحر الميت كانت تغمر المكان لكن معلمه
تبخره باتت واضحه اضافه لدراسات تؤكد
اختلاف المشهد كليا بعد 50 عاما فالبحر
الميت مهدد بالاختفاء مع دلالات انكماشه
بمعدل متر من كل عامه والبحث عن حلول
لانعاشه بات ضروره
شواطئ وتسحرت بعد تبخر المياه التي كانت
تغمرها على مر سنوات انحسار البحر الميت
ارتبط بعده اسباب اهمها تحويل اسرائيل
لمياه نهر الاردن عن مجراه الطبيعي المنصب
فيه ومع فشل العديد من المشاريع الهادفه
لانقاذ البحر الميت باتت الحلول تتجه
لاعاده تاهيل مياه نهر الاردن الذي يعد
رافدا اساسيا للبحر الميت مساء كان اخرها
اعلان النوايا بين الجانبين الاردني
والاسرائيلي تنصب حول الاهتمام بنهر
الاردن واعاده تاهيله من خلال خطط ودراسات
لم يعلن عنها بعد حتى الان يعني هو اتفاق
مبدئي بهدف تحديد الاليات والوسائل ورصد
المخصصات من قبل المجتمع الدولي للتمويل
هذا المشروع الذي يصب في مصلحه المنطقه
تراجعت خلال 20 عاما تقريبا بحسب الخبراء
خاصه مع اعت على الهطول المطريه فقط كرافد
له لا يتجاوز باحسن حالاته المئتي مليون
متر مكعب سنويا مقارنه بما كان عليه الحال
قبل تحويل مياه نهر الاردن ما يشرح حاليا
حوالي 150 مليون متر مكعب في العام بين ما
كان سابقا من كل الروافد وكل المناطق
حوالي 1800 مليون متر مكعب في العالم
فلذلك
تاهيل مياه نهر الاردن كشريان حياه للبحر
الميت بات الحل الوحيد لاسعافه او الحفاظ
على منسوبه الحالي ان امكن وما بين
مشاريعه طويه واعلان النوايا الجديده تؤكد
الحقائق اهميه البدء الفعلي بخطوات جاده
لانقاذ البحر الميت
العربيه من البحر الميت
الى اليمن حيث تعاني العشرات من ضحايا
الالغام من نساء تعز من الاعاقه جراء بدري
اطرافهن بعبوات والغام المليشه الحوثيه
واعجزنا اولئك النسوه عن ممارسه حياتهن
بشكل طبيعي جراء الاعاقه التقرير التالي
يسلط الضوء على معاناه ضحايا الالغام
الحوثيه في محافظه تعز دعونا متابعه
[موسيقى]
مني من كل شيء
اليوم الذي استعدت فيه الشابه دليله لتكون
العروس بيوم مش ام في تاريخها لقد بتر
القدم بلغم حوثي وعدل العريس عن قرار
الزواج قرار تقول الفتاه حال حياتها الى
جحيم
كثير
الان نحن اصبحنا معاقه الثلاثه ونصف لان
احنا مش رادين بيوتنا مشيردين
[موسيقى]
الاناناس
معور الرجل السلام معوض
المالكي مش هون طريقه اللغز
ماساه الاعاقه قصص تختزل بؤس الحياه لاكثر
من 360 امراه يمنيه في تعز وصبنا بعبوات
والغم
منهن في منطقه الشقب وحدها جنبي المدينه
لان الالغام بالطرق ملانا الالغام بتبيض
وتعمل لنا الالغام بجميعها الحاجه ده
الوديان المزارع بكل شيء نحن متضرر من
العودين اني اهلي اربعاء الذي هم تواجه
نحن ثلاث مبترات اسراء واحده ثانيه ثانيه
من طريقه الحوثي بالقيها الايسر
لاسيما النساء والاطفال فالمنازل في قرى
الشرقيه يقول الاهالي نسفت بعبوات
المليشيات اما عقاراتهم وممتلكاتهم صارت
منهوبه بايدي قيادات حوثيه على مدى ثمانيه
اعوام من الحرب
انتهاكات الجسيمه بحق المدنيين الى
الاحياء السكنيه سيما في منطقه الشعب
جنوبي تعز بعضها كانت بالالغام والعبوات
الناسفه وبعضها رميه بالرصاص ال سعيد
العربيه
تعز
[موسيقى]
من اليمن الى تونس بينما وضعت الهيئه
العليا المستقله للانتخابات هناك اخر
اللمسات اللوجستيه وايضا تنظيميه لاجراء
الانتخابات التشريعيه تصاعد الخلاف
القانوني والسياسي بين مختلف الاطراف
المعنيه بالانتخابات في البلاد بين مؤيد
واخر رافض ما يؤكد اهميه تركيبه البرلمان
المقبله في توضيح معالم المشهد السياسي
التونسي
هذه الاماكن المخصصه لتعليق قائمه
المترشحين للانتخابات التشريعيه باتت
جاهزه بمجرد انطلاق الحمله الانتخابيه
لاستقبال برامج المراهمين على اخذ مقاعد
في البرلمان القادم هي كما الفضاءات
العامه هيئه الانتخابات وضعت اخر لمسات
وفق الرزنامه المحدده سلفا الامر قد يبدو
عاديا الى هنا لكن خصوصيه هذا الاستحقاق
التشريعي وطابعه الاستثنائيه جعل السعيد
الى افشاله لا يترددون في انتاج كل السبل
ومنها تحريك الشارع والتوجه الى دوائر
خارجيه المعارضه التي بقيت تقريبا ولا
السنه كامله وهي تجدد وتعمل وتقوم بكل من
شانه ان يسقط هذا المشروع الذي تجى اليه
رئيس قيس سعيد تبين فشلها وتبين ان عاجزه
من ان تحرك شارع في تونس واعتقد ان اهتمام
التونسيين بالفعل هي سياسيه ولكن كذلك
اقتصاديه ومعي اسرع يحتضم اذا بين مؤيد
ورافض ومقاطع واخرين مطالبين بالتاجيل
الكل يبسط حججه واسبابه لكن الشارع
المنشغله بواقعه الاقتصادي صعب
والاجتماعيه المترديه له راي الاخر
في تونس
في عهد عشريه السوداء لحقيقه ما بوجه جديد
بوجه همم ناس فهم الطرح بالجديده
من مجموع الناخبين في مناخ سياسيا
وانتخابيا فارق منذ اعلان الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه في البلاد
اللوجستيه والبشريه لاجراء الاستحقاق
التشريعيه يتواصلوا الجدل
الانتخابات من حيث النزاهه والشفافيه
لتركيز الجمهوريه الجديده وليد عبد الله
العربيه
تونس
انطلقت سفينه بلاستيك اوديسي في رحله
بحريه من مدينه فرنسيه نحو الثلاثين مدينه
غارقه في النفايات البلاستيكيه السفينه
بدات جولاتها التي ستستمر ثلاثه اعوام من
بيروت وتهدف الى تعريف المجتمعات المحليه
على طرق لاعاده تدوير البلاستيك والنوعيه
حول اهميه استخدام هذه المواد
هذه السفينه التي كانت حلما قبل سته اعوام
تحولت الى منزل عائم يجمعهم 28 زميلا
مهمتهم محاربه التلوث
علمتني بلاستيك سيندمون ثلاثه اعوام
يبحرون خلالها من بلد الى اخر في رحله
بحريه هدفها لحد من تلوث البحار والمحيطات
بالمواد البلاستيكيه
التي تذهب الى البحر عملنا على ايجاد
شركاء للتحضير للرحله التي بداناها من
مرسي الفرنسيه ومنها انطلقنا الى بيروت
كاول محطه خارج فرنسا
من اصحاب المبادرات البيئيه الذين
استقبلتهم السفينه على مدى اسبوعين لتبادل
الخبرات مع شركاء محليين والتعرف على احدث
الطرق لتدوير النفايات
بشكل ساعه
هذه الفكره نحن عم بقدموا لنا اياها ممكن
نقدر
نطبقها بلبنان
باسمه المح ممكن تضيع مثلا يستفيدوا من
هالشي منه مصنع كثير كبير بمدينه
بيلبيشن اصغر طيب
دول سفره بماكينات تحويل البلاستيك الى
منتجات يستفاد منها في رص الارصفه وبناء
اسقف المنازل ومواسير الصرف الصحي وحتى
انتاج الكهرباء في بلدان تعاني من الظلام
مثل لبنان لكن الهدف الاساسي هو الحد من
استخدام البلاستيك الذي يصب 20 طن منه في
المحيطات كل دقيقه تغادر الانس بيروت
متجهه نحو الاسكندريه في محطه ثانيه
سيتعرف خلالها طاقم السفينه على تجربه
جديده من معاناه المدن مع المواد
البلاستيكيه غنوه يتيم العربيه بيروت
الى العناوين
سيارات مفخخه وصواريخ ايران تستهدف احزان
كرديه شمال العراق و واشنطن تندد
محاكمه عرفيه واعتقالات التعسفيه لقمع
الاحتجاجات والحرس الثوري يلوح مجددا
بالقبضه الحديديه
موسكو وكيف تتبادلان الاتهامات عن قصف
محطه زبوريجيا وتحذيرات دوليه من اللعب
بالنار
بعد استقالات الجامعيه عصفت بمنصه تويتر
اليوم موجه اقالات جديده تنتظر مئات
العاملين
اخبار الظهيره انتهت نلتقي غدا ونشره
جديده مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]